Disney's animators have returned to
arendelle for their second short film
featuring the characters from their
smash hit frozen yippie Kay may be
lovers it's Jan here and today I'll be
revealing some cool secrets about Olaf's
frozen adventure as well as hidden
details and Disney Easter eggs you may
have missed in the new animated mini
movie I'm also running a Disney Funko
pop giveaway on this video to end to
make sure you're a subscriber and leave
a comment below about this short film or
any of the frozen movies when it came to
depicting Christmas celebrations in
Olaf's frozen adventure the filmmakers
look to Scandinavian culture especially
Norway for inspiration just like they
did with frozen and that's why you'll
find tons of goats dotted around
throughout the film for example on
wrapping paper as festive ornaments and
even honors dress you see a Nordic
countries the Yule goat is a Christmas
tradition that goes back many many
centuries and though its meaning has
changed over time it's still popular
there today as a christmas ornament as
well as all those pictures of goats in
the movie originally there was also
going to be a goat character call mr.
jingles who got his name because he
swallowed a bell which meant he made
jingling noises all the time mr. jingles
would have been part of Olaf's journey
around arendelle I was going to eat all
the items Olaf collected in a sleigh
however in the end the directors decided
to drop mr. jingles from the final film
as he was taking too much focus off span
and Olaf hidden among the many gifts
that Olaf gathers on his travels is a
sweet little easter egg to Disney short
film The Ballad of Nessie which was made
by the same people who directed Olaf's
frozen adventure many thanks to all the
eagle-eyed people who pointed Nessie out
to me on my video for the film's trailer
the scene where Olaf gulps down an
entire fruitcake is a shout out to
another short film made by the directors
of Olaf's frozen adventure in the Disney
holiday specials prep and landing which
were about a hi-tech team of elves there
are several jokes about fruitcake
so the filmmakers decided to continue
that tradition in Olaf's new short film
and there's a festive tradition that
Olaf discovers during his adventures is
the feast of Saint Lucia which in a
number of Nordic countries is celebrated
on the 13th of December and includes a
girl typically wearing a white gown and
red sash together with a wreath
candles on her head the father's being a
fun moment the scene where Olaf gets a
candy cane actually includes a couple of
cool Disney Easter eggs
when Olaf replaces his carrot nose with
the candy cane and cries out sugar rush
it's a callback to the scene in the
original frozen movie where Olaf got his
first carrot nose from Anna we made
candy canes together on top of that the
scene is also a clever shout-out to
Disney's wreck-it Ralph film where Ralph
enters a go-kart racing candy filled
game called sugar rush which features a
candy cane forest wreck-it Ralph 2 is
Disney's next animated movie so it's
nice to see it get a nod here there's
also a touch of adult humor in this
scene as Olaf spinning eyes remind me of
the way characters in movies like
Pinocchio and the good dinosaur react
when they get rather different rushes as
a star of the short film Olaf gets some
fun new looks with a variety of festive
accessories including a bowtie made from
ice which mirrors the design of Elsa's
signature snowflake and highlights a
strong connection between Elsa and a
favorite little snowman if you look
carefully at Elsa and honors dresses in
this film you'll notice lots of small
but important details that are full of
meaning for example the animators
deliberately chose similar colors for
the sisters clothes to emphasize just
how close they've become and to reflect
the fact that the sisters team up in
this film in contrast to frozen where
they had to spend so much time apart
Elsa's gown is bluey gray and has a
jeweled bodice which includes a design
based on her snowflake the animators
spent a lot of time making sure the
snowflake and diamond shaped gems on the
dress reflected light in a realistic way
so they'd look clear and sparkly but
after all their hard work the gems look
so sparkly that they were actually a bit
distracting so they had to dial back the
shine a bit also if you look at the
further tops Elsa's gown scattered
within it you'll see little frosted
Holliday berries which are a reminder of
Elsa's icy powers and you can also see
them as accessories in both Elsa and
honors her again emphasizing the
closeness of the frozen sisters as for
Elsa's snowflake that also features on
her cape in a pattern
for shadows of beautiful ice tree she
makes in the film as piranhas close the
dusty blue violet color of her new
outfit complements the dusty blue gray
color of her sister's gown and little
aspects of Ana's costume also point to
the fact that she and Kristoff are now
together for example take a look at the
sashes they were in the film if you
listen closely to the film score for
instance when Elsa and honour remember
their childhood he'll hear the return of
some familiar themes from arendelle
however composer Christophe Beck has
given those musical themes a new twist
adding a warm and cozy feel so that they
fit the new holiday setting as for the
new songs by Kate Anderson and Alissa
Sam soul you won't just hear them sung
in the film you'll also hear their music
woven into the score for example the
opening track kicks off with a little
bit of when were together and that
melody is used throughout the film the
idea being that when you finally hear
the character sing the song towards the
end it already feels comforting and
familiar like any good holiday song now
what was your favorite moment in Olaf's
frozen adventure and what do you want to
see happen in the frozen sequel let me
know in the comments below and also
don't forget to subscribe for your
chance to win a Disney Funko pop and if
you enjoyed this hit that like button
turn on your notifications to get my
upcoming videos and tap the screen to
watch more of my Disney and Pixar
Animation videos including Coco's Easter
eggs thanks for watching and see you
next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers